Sometimes I'll get, I'll get,
like, Irish eyebrow.
- Right. Right.
- You know what I mean?
- You gotta pull out...
- What's the Irish eyebrow?
That's when it gets like,
those Irish writers,
- they get those eyebrows.
- Yeah.
And then you look like
some old Irish writer from the
old days.
What do you think
Brooklyn thinks of you
- saying that you even tweeze
your eyebrows?
- Yeah, that's bad.
But the new Brooklyn probably
agrees with it.
The old guys, "I used to like
Colin, now he tweezes
his eyebrows?
I can't watch
his stuff anymore."
I was a little metrosexual
back in the day. Now I'm not so
much anymore.
You're not?
- We'll be the judge of that.
- What's up everybody?
I'm Chris Distefano,
aka Chrissy Nipples
and I'm here with Colin
Quinn from Brooklyn, New York!
The hell's your problem?
What's the stupidest thing
your mom ever made you wear?
She didn't make me wear
it, but she actually bought me,
I had an Australian hat.
- Right.
- So it was almost like a half a
pimp hat...
- Yeah. Right. Nice.
- ... from the early 70s. Like
half Superfly...
- ... and half of the
Australian, like, outback hat?
- Right.
And the mistake she made
was to let me wear it to school
- 'cause then you're a target.
- Yeah, and then you get beat
up.
So my mother bought me
a neon green swim cap
with flowers on the side
by the ears.
I wore that thing.
Johnny Zingrone from Middle
Village hit me in the face with
a wiffle ball bat
and was like, "Nice swim cap,
Flower Face!"
That's what happens
when you grow up in Brooklyn,
- Queens area.
- You get dropped.
Here's a stupid question.
- What's the last dream you had?
- Huh. What's the last dream I
had?
Huh? By the way, huh means, huh,
I'm not going to tell
the last two I really had.
I'll think of a clean one.
No, I'm trying to think, what's
the last time I had a good
dream?
- What did I have a good
dream...
- It's gotta be
either sex or murder or else
we don't want to hear it.
I always have a dream
that some secret agency
is, like, you know, like,
they're knocking on my mother's
window.
Like we need to see your son
and they have, like, a door
open, but the door
- open, it's got like this green
light coming out.
- Right.
And they want, they always want
to ask me
questions about aliens.
- It's like an abduction.
- It's either that or a secret.
They wanted you to reveal
something about yourself
that you're not
comfortable revealing yet.
- Well, should I just do it now?
- But in today's society is
fine.
I'm gay!
- You're the one that should
know all this stuff...
- Here's a stupid question.
When you were a kid, were
you more scared of cooties or
ghosts?
I was scared of ghosts
for a minute, yeah.
- I was scared of ghosts.
- I'm still scared of
ghosts. People,
everybody wants me to get a
house. My mother's like,
"Oh, you got to buy a house,
you get a family."
It's like, I need to live
in a studio apartment.
I need to open the door
and visually scan the room
because guess where, guess
where the ghosts
and the murderers
are on any floor?
No, you're right. I've slept
since I was a child, I've slept
with either a giant butcher
knife or an ax for many years.
Mini hand axe under my
pillow, right next to my, next
to, I'm sleeping.
It's in that little cut
on the bed right there.
- Right.
- Like that. I sleep
like that and my hand's
- usually on it.
- With an axe?
- Yep.
- Still to this day?
No, now I have an Afghani knife,
it's like a killing knife.
- I have a grenade launcher.
- Guy who gave it to me told
me there's a couple of bodies
- on it, too.
- Really? So that's what you
have right now?
The Afghan knife in your bed?
- Yeah.
- Wow. I dare somebody
to try to rob your -
Oh my God, they're in for the
surprise of their life.
All right, Colin. Did you have a
good time on the show?
- I did.
- Thanks for being here. I give
you a stupid gift now.
All right.
You're a big history guy,
I'm a big history guy.
I thought why not
Colonial hats
- Oh!
- that are really not colonial
they kind of look like a...
Like a colonial stripper would
wear them. Do you think we'd
be good soldiers
in the Revolutionary War?
- I would run.
- You have no choice. Where
would you run to, there's
nowhere to run to? This right
here, your neighborhood,
all the battles are happening
right there.
The whole British army
guess where they entered
the United States?
Or the 13 colonies as
that were called back then?
Denyse Ferry
in Bay Ridge, Brooklyn.
- Take my hat off to you,
the British.
- You got a bad rap.
We should have kept you
in charge of this country.
Yeah but thank you for Adele.
It's not a popular opinion.
These gifts really stunk.
- Yeah I know.
- I'm being serious.
I should have, I'll think
more carefully.
I mean, I got this at
the 99 cent store.
You're not grateful!
That's what I'd like
to do to your face right there.
Just...